deux secondes s'excuse aujourd'hui on se
retrouve de nouveau sur carlo qu'est
parti pour la grande revanche halal je
sais que tu aimes bien premières
chansons ah pardon excusez moi je
m'enflamme aux attentions g10 et de jeux
de mots houston demander trop de
concurrence
m
yes yes yes
yes yes yes je vais vomir sur son groupe
il est nous sommes 12e [ __ ] ce tro t 1
font leur clip tout le bordel
allez allez allez allez ça va ça va ça
ne se passera pas comme ça
j'ai pourtant
menteur on n'a même pas aux bas salaires
merde tu es surpris x600 est de taille
côté programme d'essai ce boxing
ridicule parce qu'aussi bien voilà c'est
ridicule ça c'est là ça s'est fait au
grand père au coeur du caire
c'était nul bon ok c'est le moment la
peur poursuit la posture mais alors qu
la rouge bravo que la rouge bravo même
un dragon fly out je suis seule ses
trois filles quoi profitent ils sont là
tous les jours je rage mais je donne
tout possible les hydres est détectée
chez pas l'apparence physique de la
personne
pascoe la gta clément wendel c'est bon
j'ai compris il ya une chanson sur
laquelle personne pour me battre
oui c'est bel et bien mièvre à skis mois
flower clip descend tout de suite de là
je veux te voir au dernier
comme la tienne nous sommes ce qui est
juste m'intéresse fortement 27e sur 33
bon il ya un petit progrès j'étais en
string sur une boule destruction par moi
j'étais en slip sur une chaise roulante
alors ça va la prochaine à les cours
sont les gens et ce qu'il chante
vraiment comme si c'était un concert
devant 2000 personnes devant leur envie
je sais qu'elle est mec fait des
concerts vraiment à 8700 points sur dix
huit pas tu t'appelles faut voir mieux
puisqu il n'y a pas de problème toi tu
t'appelles flow my l'aide nile et dan
miles & more sandeagle powerclip tu as
un micro de où on a trop on a tous vu un
joueur que moi en excuses du micro elle
est comme ça qui fera les meilleurs pas
de danse on va lancer le 12 ou encore la
relance à coude non ça c'est notamment
ce que tout le monde c'est à dire de la
chanson tout le reste n'a jamais entendu
parler ou effet la cabeza personne n'a
jamais reçu cette phrase et la dgf werc
depuis la fin mai en espagne soit le mec
comme ça t'en sors didier cette fois
yoga magasin
rue rff et catella sa part le bon steak
en fait c'est un fit entre deux épouses
elles s'ajoutent aux nouveaux locaux il
aurait bombardé par erreur
je vais tout chercheur danois restent
toujours toi
on est combien on évoque 7e 28 pour une
fois que tu la montée c'est quoi ce
délire
alors là je chante gros demandez pas
trop ce qu'ils appellent chansons en
allemand pour pourrir qu'il ya pas à
tout donc au tgs ya du tout que tel
c'est bon c'est seul groupe allemand
busch connais je suis désolé pour
appeler bien sûr celle ci on va voir si
tu gères c'est dans l'ambiance
ok attention alors j'espère car pas du
tout d'allemand aux noms et les anglais
au nom
m
ça y est
oui